this is a great excerpt from federalist
51 by james madison and just as a
reminder the federalist papers which
were written by hamilton madison john
jay were an attempt to get the
constitution passed to get it ratified
so these were really kind of op-eds that
they were publishing to convince people
but this is a great passage
if men were angels no government would
be necessary if angels were to govern
men
neither external nor internal controls
on government would be necessary
in framing a government which is to be
administered by men
over men the great difficulty lies in
this
you must first enable the government to
control the governed
and in the next place oblige it to
control itself
and it goes on to talk about how we can
keep government from becoming too
powerful
by so contriving the interior structure
of the government as that its several
constituent parts may by their mutual
relations be the means of keeping each
other in their proper places and so
remember this was in defense of the
constitution so arguably this was in
place that somehow this constitution had
contrived an interior structure so that
the several constituent parts of
government by their mutual relations
would keep each other in their proper
places or you could even say keep each
other in check so in line with this
passage there's really two big ideas
embedded in the constitution as to how
our government is structured
the first is this notion of separation
of powers
we have three branches of government you
have your executive headed by the
president you have your legislative
branch which is congress legislative
and you have your judicial branch which
is the us supreme court
and this notion of separation of powers
is that you have these fairly
independent branches of government and
the idea was to make them reasonably
independent so that one group one branch
could not take over the others the
legislative branch congress they're
charged with budget and they're charged
with creating and passing laws the
executive branch headed by the president
is supposed to execute run the
government based on the laws that
congress passes and you have the
judicial branch that would decide
whether things say laws that congress is
passing or actions that the executive's
taking they say hey is that
constitutional or they can interpret
laws so these different powers are put
into these different branches the powers
are separate
now related to that is another very
powerful idea and this is keeping each
other in their proper places and so this
is the idea of checks and balances each
of these can't do whatever they want
they're all balancing each other they
all have checks on each other for
example the executive can
veto
the legislative branch can veto a law
passed by congress but then the
legislative branch can override that
veto the legislative branch they control
the budget so it's not like the
president or the executive can do
whatever they want or that they can just
spend as much money as they want and the
judicial branch in both cases can be a
check and they're saying hey you're
doing something that is unconstitutional
or we're going to interpret the laws
that the legislature has passed the
executive appoints the judicial but even
there you have to get congressional
buy-in so once again you have these
independent branches of government all
the power isn't in one and they are
interdependent they provide checks and
balances on each other and this is all
about what federalist 51 is talking
about so that by their mutual relations
they are the means of keeping each other
in their proper places